votre vrai nom c'est Don Juan Moreno
errer IRI Ménez c'est vrai que pour
devenir Zorro c'est un nom super
Jean Reno pourquoi n'êtes-vous jamais
venu dans une de mes émissions
auparavant je sais pas je me souviens
plus je vous fais pas non pas du tout
gentil mais oui vous êtes gentil vous
êtes costaud de toute façon je sais pas
j'ai vachement insisté
[Applaudissements]
c'est dommage parce que je vous ai mis
un beau coup en fait un mec qui a débuté
sa carrière dans les bidasses aux
grandes manœuvre avec Paul Prébois et
Michel Galabru et qui a fini par faire
mission impossible avec Tom Cruise
runnin avec Robert De Niro où le Da
Vinci Code avec Tom Hanks ça mérite un
triomphe quand même merde
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
français parfaitement mondialisé un
espagnol né au Maroc devenu une star au
Japon en jouant un apnée italien
exactement j'ai vécu toute ma vie dans
une valise voilà alors vous êtes né le
30 juillet 1948 à Casablanca de parents
andalou ayant fui l'Espagne de Franco
votre vrai nom c'est Don Juan Moreno
errer irimenez c'est vrai que pour
devenir zoo c'est un nom super
et le rôle était pris mais pour devenir
un acteur français c'est un peu plus
compliqué
Jean Reno comme Alain Delon ou Jean
Gabin exactement plus simple tout le
monde s'en souvient vous avez eu raison
alors en France difficile en arrivant au
Maroc votre père vendait des cheveux
avant ma naissance alors après il a été
boulanger ça c'est vrai il dormait dans
des sacs de farine ça c'est vrai et
après il a été l'identifiste au petit
marocain l'île typique c'est les gens
qui mettent les gens qui tapent pour
avoir la ligne à l'envers pour pouvoir
imprimer c'est dur quand même oui c'est
ça l'ouvrier j'y ai pas de blé quoi on
était pas nul pierres mais on n'était
pas riche votre mère était couturière
elle fabriquait des manteaux mais des
manteaux au Maroc ça devait pas être une
affaire très florissante
et il y avait un peu de pluie et je
pensais ça il était 7h du soir j'ai des
flashs comme ça et aujourd'hui vous êtes
potes avec Jay-Z et Beyoncé quel
parcours Jean Reno non
ça c'est ça c'est par le biais de ma
femme
[Applaudissements]
quand Jésus sort de sa banlieue alors
quand beyoncé vient dîner chez vous
est-ce que vous lui mettez deux chaises
pour qu'elle pose ses cuisses
pas méchants vous avez vu son tour de
chant ouais un jour je l'ai vu je suis
tombé du fauteuil à cause de ses cuisses
alors vous êtes potes avec Jay-Z Nicolas
Sarkozy il y en a un des deux qui
voulait absolument que vous lui
présentiez l'autre c'est lequel
la réponse est facile
je vais garder ça pour moi
alors Sarkozy était votre témoin de
mariage est-ce que vous serez témoin à
son procès Jean
peut-être on ne sait jamais de quoi la
vie sera faite alors
parallèlement aux visiteurs 3 et exprime
des Belges 4 est-ce que vous allez jouer
dans Sarko 2 la revanche j'ai du mal de
parler de mes opinions politiques en
public vous êtes affiché avec Sarkozy
quand même oui mais parce que par amitié
non oui
c'est comme la religion c'est quelque
chose qui est privé quelle histoire que
votre vie le petit andalou qui découvre
sa vocation à l'âge de 12 ans en jouant
les Précieuses ridicules et qui va
devenir une star Hollywood et un demi
dieu au Japon c'est fou parce que vous
êtes bien renseigné
ça vient de loin quand même donc 12 ans
à la vérité puisque je suis là pour une
pièce de théâtre ça vient de des
coulisses du théâtre de des sons des
odeurs de cette ambiance qu'il y a entre
les loges et la scène le bois
les sons encore une fois les odeurs le
bruissement des étoffes la loge des
femmes tout ça et pour moi était plein
de promesses quoi plein de il fallait
aller là il y a que moi
tu pourras te mettre une
gaine de temps en temps
alors j'ai beaucoup de succès au Japon
surtout avec les femmes d'ailleurs il
paraît que la première phrase que vous
avez su dire en japonais c'est non ce
bébé n'est pas de moi
alors il y a une autre phrase que vous
avez apprise très rapidement aussi c'est
bonjour il est où le chèque pour la pub
vous voulez qu'on regarde une de vos
pubs au Japon
[Musique]
alors
ça veut dire quoi de quoi est-il
question dans cette publicité il faut
dire que ça fait à peu près 17 ans que
je travaille au Japon uniquement pour
Toyota et donc il y a eu une évolution
sur mon personnage on m'a groupé là avec
un chat un chat qui est qui guide la
jeunesse à chaque fois qu'elle a des
problèmes et ils ont pris ce chat ils
m'ont posé la question ils m'ont dit
Jean est-ce que tu vois il y a que toi
qui peut faire un chat mais évidemment
et alors j'ai dit où est la pâtée on m'a
montré une boîte de pâté c'est comme ça
que j'ai commencé d'accord
une explication très claire très précis
de Jean Reno
très très solide pourtant après le grand
bleu qui a été un succès phénoménal vous
n'avez pas su gérer votre célébrité la
pression du succès a été trop forte vous
avez pété les plombs vous dites j'étais
gavé de voyage d'hôtels d'argent de Nana
et d'ailleurs mon couple a explosé avant
le succès lorsque vous parlez
tout le monde détourne la tête
et on va regarder quelqu'un d'autre
après le succès dès que vous ouvrez la
bouche tout le monde écoute qu'est-ce
qu'il dit oh là là c'est tellement
formidable ce qu'il dit qu'est-ce qu'il
est beau voilà et ça il faut le digérer
il faut apprendre le digérer et revenir
sur terre et oublier et essayez pas de
redevenir totalement anonyme mais
essayez de retrouver cette humanité qui
a fait que vous êtes à cet endroit là
j'espère que je suis clair très clair
merci c'est mieux que la pub alors
évidemment le succès du Grand Bleu des
phénoménal la rencontre avec Besson
c'était sur ce fameux film les bidasses
aux grandes manœuvres avec Paul Prébois
et Michel Galabru et lui il était donc
Besson assistant réalisateur de Raphaël
delparre évidemment inoubliable
réalisateur de film et lorsqu'il est
très marrant c'est que le matin vous
arriviez tous les deux super en avance
et moi je suis j'arrive avant lui encore
avant lui et il supporte pas ça vous
êtes devenu complice
c'est comme ça que ça commençait alors
ce qui est très marrant en fait c'est
que vous êtes tourné avec les plus
grands réalisateurs du monde mais le
film déterminant dans votre carrière
c'est les bidasses aux grandes manœuvres
quelque part oui bien sûr bien entendu
c'est un navet
ça évolue
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de
innarditude abonnez-vous et mettez un
pouce bleu